Allé Rasta, avances ! C'est parti
Avances ! Avances !
Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
En compagnie de Alex et ScottyFive
On est là pour la partie 2, ici on a déjà trouvé 2 armes. Plutôt pas mal
Ici la dernière fois c'était rempli
Il y avait même un clic-clac, des choses comme ça
Je sens que ça accroche encore
A mon avis, on va en sortir plein
Il y a du très lourd
Qu'est ce que c'est que ce machin ?
Un morceau d'échafaudage, non ?
Bizarre, ça commence bien
Oh, un bout de vélo
Un cadre de vélo
Plus gros qu'un vélo
Olala les sachets plastiques
Il est vieux celui là
Une mobylette peut être
Le cadre paraît large pour un vélo
Il n'y pas un pistolet de collé cette fois ?
Ouais ça serait bien
Deux lancés et déjà deux gros trucs
Oh ! Regardes
Bien joué
C'est un pied de biche énorme
Un démonte pneu
Une petite manivelle
Attention, il est chaud Quentin
il fait du jardinage en même temps
Tu l'as perdu dans le buisson
Il est là
Il l'a retrouvé
Bien joué
Il y a une herse dessous
Des dents
Oh regardez ça
Comme quoi, le brossage de dent, c'est important
Attention à votre hygiène dentaire, sinon vous allez finir comme ça
Il y a un truc
Il n'est pas vieux celui là
Pas mal ça
Sympa
C'est un moteur de Solex
Regardez ce TikTokeur
Oh ! Le couteau
Ce n'est pas un Laguiole
Allé, encore un cadre
Je pari que c'est un moteur de Solex encore
Oh ! Une gouttière
Vous avez vu la puissance des aimants
Reparti à l'eau
Il y a peut être une anguille là dedans
Il y en a dans les tubes en général
Ca c'est de la manivelle !
On est déjà pas mal, ça avance vite
C'est pour attacher les sangles ça je crois
Un cliquet
Rasta qui nous fait sa petite sieste
Voilà le petit panier
Il m'en manquait un dans mon frigidaire
Pour mettre les bières
Ah, c'est du câble
Du cuivre !
Il y a peut être quelque chose de lesté
Un cadavre !
Ah ! Le premier
Bon, il y a quoi au bout ?
Un cadavre ? Un enrouleur ?
C'est plus le poids d'un cadavre
Oh non !
Qu'est ce que tu nous sors ?
Ah, j'ai le câble encore
Vas-y doucement
Un côté à lâché
Un enrouleur !
Il n'y a pas que l'enrouleur
Ce n'est pas vieux
Il y a un autre câble
Regardez tous les embouts
La dernière fois on a trouvé un amplificateur ici
Il y a des ports d'ordinateurs
Les factures d'électricités étaient trop chère il a tout balancé
Un autre enrouleur ?
Voilà !
Bien joué
Avec le cuivre tu as fait ta journée
Un pédalier de vélo
C'est quoi ?
Un détecteur
Il faut compter combien pour un bon aimant ?
Le site Maison de la Détection
Avec le code promo PECHEURDETRESORS
Sinon tu as le code ScottyFive et tu as -40%
Moi j'ai 40% et eux 5%
Je plaisante
C'est au bon vouloir de la personne
Les pêcheur fou à l'aimant !
On a besoin de toi
Olala il a sauté à l'eau
Il va débloquer l'aimant
Rasta, qu'est ce que c'est ?
Tu es allé dans l'eau pour rien, ça ne fonctionne pas
Tu veux le masque de plongé ?
C'est trop profond
Il y a 5 mètres de fond
Tu as des affaires de rechange ?
Non
Il fait chaud
Elle était bonne ?
Il va te sécher regardes
Enfin la trouvaille
C'est lourd
C'est pas mal ça
C'est juste magnifique
Quelque chose qui n'a rien à faire dans l'eau, 40 kg de plus
Ce n'est pas très vieux encore
Il y a la marque ?
Il y a le numéro de série ici
Germany BMW
Arrière gauche
Regardes la munition
Je ne sais pas si on a le droit de le montrer ça
Bien sûr que si, c'est une 22LR
C'est une grosse 22LR alors
Bien joué les gars
Il y en a peut être d'autres, on continue
Ca vient
Je l'ai perdu mais j'ai quand même quelque chose
La même ogive que la munition de tout à l'heure
Une belle ogive
Il est énervé aujourd'hui
Ca pèse lourd, c'est de la fonte
Viens, on a le marteau de Thor là
Il arrive
Si c'est ça !
Il ne faut pas qu'il se bloque en bas
Vous abusez 200kg quand même
Sisi 200kg, tu vas voir
C'est énorme, regardes cette pièce
Elle doit faire, 70kg
Non ! Tu es fou
Plus de 100kg
200 je ne sais pas mais plus de 100 kg finalement
Non ...
Tu le soulève ?
Oui
Tu le prend sur la clavicule aussi, non ?
Facile
Voilà !
Il ne pèse pas du tout 100kg
Une pièce qui n'a encore une fois rien à faire dans l'eau
Belle trouvaille quand même
J'ai trouvé une clef à pipe
J'ai quelque chose je crois
Encore une clef !
Une clef plate de 12, il y a écrit
Ca vient
On l'a cassé je crois
Oh non, il y a qu'un morceau là
C'est un vélo pour l'instant
C'est bien dans les rochers
Il n'y avait pas que ça
Il y a une petite tache d'essence
Vas y
Une mobylette ça serait bien
Ca y est ! Jolie
C'est un Peugeot 103 ?
Bien joué
Elle est magnifique
C'est un Motobécane
Plus qu'a trouver le propriétaire qui doit encore être en train de nager
C'est bien ça, dernière trouvaille, magnifique
De belles trouvailles aujourd'hui encore
Regardez les découvertes
Belle session ?
Ouais, super session !
Belle pêche ScottyFive ?
Nickel mon cousin